joining me now is former secretary of
state mike pompeo
secretary pompeo why should the world
community
honor beijing with its presence
laura thanks for having me on that was a
pretty good catalog of what's taking
place
with the chinese communist party today
we shouldn't
honor the chinese communist party with
this indeed
president biden talks about wanting to
lead coalitions great this is a
wonderful place to start
and we did this kind of thing with
respect to china you remember lord when
we first went after huawei we recognized
this was dangerous for the american
people
it was a lonely place out there for the
secretary of state travel in the world
but we did it we led and we got 60
nations to join us and say nope we're
not going to put this chinese technology
inside of our national systems we should
do the same thing with the olympics we
should get every country to recognize
that we don't want to honor the chinese
communist party with this
and i'll say this too remember july 1st
of last year they passed a national
security law what athlete wants to
travel to
china and know that if you said anything
about the chinese communist party you're
likely to be arrested
this this law can arrest you anywhere at
all time it was designed to shut people
up we've seen that happen remember that
the issue with the general manager of
the houston rockets
this national security law is dangerous
i would tell any athlete thinking about
going to china be very careful about the
things you say
that's precisely the kind of prohibition
that the chinese communist party wants
to do
so they can continue to expand their
propaganda efforts it was a bad idea for
the ioc to award an america ought to
lead
the movement of these games to some
place other than china
on a scale of one to ten one being the
least likely ten being the most likely
what will the biden administration do do
you think
boy i'm i'm going to i'm going to root
for them to get it right laura
you know we haven't seen this we haven't
seen we have we have we haven't seen
tremendous strength there yet
uh we've seen them declare that yes in
fact there was genocide but we haven't
seen them honor
the commitments to come with
understanding that genocide is taking
place inside of china we saw what
happened
in the previous administration we saw
them where rwanda was engaged in
genocide and we saw them walk away from
it
as the same actors today at the state
department i hope they get
it right here and secretary blinken has
just back to that point
uh has said that he agreed with you that
china's guilty of genocide he said my
judgment remains that genocide was
committed against the uyghurs
and that hasn't changed so again the
secretary of state says
they are guilty of committing ongoing
genocide against a million muslims
or more we don't really know the whole
figure and yet we're going to trot over
to beijing
and and give xi the greatest propaganda
coup that he could publish i mean
the fact that we're even considering
that to me is i
i it almost takes your breath away we
had to ask you about the airstrikes
tonight
in syria a lot of people out there
tonight saying
you know look this is ran back forces in
syria
response to rocket attacks in iraq uh we
don't know all the intel but
um look i was critical of president
trump's bombing of syria and likewise uh
seemed skeptical of this isn't this what
china wants as well for us to get bogged
down even more in the middle east mr
secretary
laurie you've got to protect your force
you've got to establish deterrence we
did this
a couple times it was effective i don't
know what they struck or what targets
they went after
i hope it just wasn't uh bombs in the
desert i hope it really went after
something that threatened the united
states of america if not
it's useless you don't need to get
bogged down there to take an airstrike
i'm confident that we could do it with
getting in and getting out
we've got to make sure that we deter the
iranians every place
weakness and appeasement of the iranians
will only be rewarded with more terror
from them
secretary pompeo one final question a
lot of young people across the country
really love tick-tock
you guys in the trump administration
were trying to force the sale
of tick tock by chinese interests and
apparently now that's on hold
by the biden administration and it looks
like china
china's interest in tick tock will
continue at least for the time being
how big a mistake is that
laura my advice to parents hasn't
changed to quote nancy reagan just say
no
tell your kids to stay away from it
they're informational their friends
information a lot of data will be in the
hands of the chinese communist party
no parent should want that i hope the
bite administration will continue down
the same path we did and try and
prevent the chinese communist party from
being inside of our
telecommunications infrastructure and
stealing american information here at
home
secretary pompeo thank you so much